uh do you follow hockey now i i can't
yeah one of my favorite pictures ever
with the cup was when ovechkin was
passed out and he had his arm around it
after all those years waiting i was just
like that's awesome in in sports now
they just i think there's a hockey
player that a big name right now that
didn't take the uh he won't take the
shot so uh okay so they he's out of the
game and he's losing millions of dollars
like kyrie irving right on basketball
i'm not following that now do you have
your shots
uh you should ask me that before i came
in here yeah i'm a non-vaxxer are you no
i'm kidding no i uh yeah i got him we
have non-baxters here yeah actually one
of them is your biggest fan yeah might
at this point i don't care whether
somebody does or not i just stay six
feet away and i wear my mask and if
people want to do what they're going to
do i just don't care right you don't
care yeah well i mean it does
will you get yourself how wait
the wasted energy
of caring
about someone who doesn't care
is just stupid so it's just like you
don't care then i i don't care but i
don't want to hear about it and i don't
want to hear your theories
as your webmd horseshit about it i don't
want to hear that so everybody's an
expert now yeah well my favorite thing
was somebody goes yeah i'm unvaxxed i'm
facts it's like we're all vaccinated
you're just saying no to this one and
we're all alive and there's seven
billion people on this [ __ ] planet
which is probably not is obviously not a
good thing
um because of vaccinations and all
plagues you know that's a theory because
there's so many people on the planet
that they're trying to get rid of some
of us
yeah i know my thing is like so why
would they get rid of the obedient ones
i have a list
they they want to get rid of they want
to get rid of the rebels the ones who
aren't going to listen so you're going
to get rid of all of us sheeple
so you can have these [ __ ] [ __ ]
that are going to question everything
you know they believe in any
conspiracies
absolutely i love conspiracies
everything is a conspiracy and people go
there's no conspiracy every time you
would go out you'd conspire with your
friends where where you can go to get
served
you know which had the hottest chicks
that maybe you were going to get lucky
you as a group always do that this
business the way business works is
conspiracy so you believe to to come to
uh like somebody told me that's my
daughter no i don't mean like ridiculous
because that's the thing about
conspiracy theory is it all good oh then
you think the moon's made out of cheese
and you have a tin foil hat on like you
know i don't think it's a conspiracy
that corporations and banks dictate our
foreign policy i don't i also don't
think you know that you know when you do
look at the fda or something like that
and people who used to work in big
pharmaceuticals suddenly work for them
and they're maybe getting aside money to
approve stuff that's not conspiracy
that's the dirty filthy shitty ways that
sociopaths operate so i'm not a hundred
percent
um against uh that and um conspiracy
theory but the reason why i rationalize
the vax the vaccine
was because i know that these illuminati
people don't want to have to dig their
own ditches so they need us to be
running on the wheel and if they were
going to try to eliminate a bunch of
people which they're probably going to
have to do
the rate we're going
right right 130 degree days now was so
it was like in four or five cities that
never happened that's literally too hot
to even go outside
and i was at the gym and i'm watching
the weatherman talking about the weather
he's literally describing the beginning
of our ability to live on this planet
with a big smile on his face and no
one's saying hey maybe you don't need 50
flat screens tvs in your in your house
um you know see look yeah i am into it i
am into it a little bit that's fantastic
you ever considered having your own kids
show
you i get it he's doing the avoiding
thing i freaked you out a little bit
sooner no you did i'm telling you that
i'm freaked out by what's happening you
believe people essentially are in
cahoots so i'm saying no i believe that
there's like since the beginning of time
there's people that want to try and run
as much as they can run like one of the
things that i think should be illegal is
making stuff like designed
obsolescence that's how you say the word
that it's designed to break after a
little while so you then have to buy a
new thing especially if it's made out of
plastic and now we're learning oh that's
what we did with the car industry yeah
and it stay and it's it goes out in the
ocean it's gonna stay there for 800
to a thousand years after every time you
order like food or something like the
stupid plastic thing that you had a
burger in so you could get a burger
cause you didn't want to go down the
street you didn't have to hunt for it or
anything it's totally for your
convenience and then they take that
thing and it ends up in the ocean for a
thousand [ __ ] years
um
no but why would they what's the answer
to that
what's the answer to that there is no
answer to that
there isn't so it's just going to end
yes we're going to end it yes the
world's going to be it is dude if you
can't get on
after this my dad's going to be taking
mushrooms
you're depressing me
no because it's set up that um
i just feel that empathetic people that
care
don't want to lead
um they don't they don't and don't you
think i think so much empathy that you
want to bring people with you like come
i care about you follow me i have people
like right there and stuff right that's
her name that is leading and trying to
take charge of all the problems that
you're talking about yeah and there's
white guys that can dunk a basketball i
mean there's always going to be an
example of of the abnormal thing but i
think most people that are honest and
good people if they get into those
situations when they see how filthy and
awful the game is like they can't handle
it it's just too overwhelmingly
depressing and they go maybe i'll just
start a little apple stand and i'll just
in my little patch of the world try to
make it better i mean that's i don't
know you've got to feed six billion
people
and you're saying because in the western
culture we order food to go and it comes
in plastic containers that that's going
to
expedite the end of the world it's going
to make it happen quicker is that yes
that's exactly what i'm saying okay
so do you think that's why they're
trying to find ways to get into space
and
get people up into space if this world
should collapse no i don't understand
that at all there's no air up there
i guess maybe if we can get to another
earth
you know one of these other earths that
they're saying there's all these earths
out there i mean this is way above my
pay grade and also i don't even this is
just stuff that i think about oh don't
get that distant look on your face okay
i don't want to think you know one of
the right hair you got that old
is your boldness for the truth
you you're bold whether you realize it
or not your comedy comes from a place of
i'm gonna tell you what i'm thinking and
this is along those lines yes but that
doesn't mean it's true well no it don't
have to be true but it's also
you can enrage people like i mean we we
everybody talks about cancel culture but
i think that your name and chappelle's
name are in one i wouldn't say after the
week he's had no
does that scare you he is in like the
comedy cuban missile crisis right now he
is
[Music]
you